what we're going to read together in
this video is what has become known as
Martin Luther King's letter from a
Birmingham jail which he wrote from a
jail cell in 1963 after he and several
of his associates were arrested in
Birmingham Alabama as they non-violently
protested segregation there and I'm
going to read an excerpt of it I
encourage you to read it in its entirety
it is one of the most powerful documents
frankly I have ever read and Martin
Luther King often gets a lot of credit
as an amazing speaker people say he
could read the phone book and it would
move people but this also speaks to what
an incredible writer he was not only is
it moving but it really gives the
philosophical underpinnings of the civil
rights movement of the 1960s and many
people attribute the Civil Rights Act of
1964 passed by Congress as being heavily
influenced by Martin Luther King's
letter now what motivated Martin Luther
King to write this letter was a
statement made in a newspaper by eight
Alabama clergymen which encouraged the
protesters to wait saying that yes we
are sympathetic to the in justices but
they should be resolved in the courts
and not through the type of protest the
type of tension that Martin Luther King
and his fellow protesters were creating
and so here's just an excerpt of what
Martin Luther King wrote you may well
ask why direct action why sit-ins
marches and so forth isn't negotiation a
better path
you're quite right in calling for
negotiation indeed this is the very
purpose of direct action nonviolent
direct action seeks to create such a
crisis and foster such attention that a
community which has constantly refused
to negotiate is forced to confront the
issue it seeks so to dramatize the issue
that it can no longer be ignored my
citing the creation of tension as part
of the work of the nonviolent resistor
may sound rather shocking but I must
confess that I am Not Afraid of the word
tension I have earnestly opposed violent
tension but there is a type of
constructive nonviolent tension which is
necessary for growth
just as Socrates felt that it was
necessary to create a tension in the
mind so that individuals could rise from
the bondage of myths and half-truths to
the unfettered realm of creative
analysis and objective appraisal so must
we see the need for non-violent gadflies
to create the kind of tension in society
that will help men rise from the dark
depths of prejudice and racism to the
majestic heights of understanding and
brotherhood the purpose of our direct
action program is to create a situation
so crisis packed that it will inevitably
open the door to negotiation I guess it
is easy for those who have never felt
the stinging darts of segregation to say
wait but when you have seen vicious mobs
lynch your mothers and fathers at will
and drown your sisters and brothers at
whim when you have seen hate-filled
policemen curse kick brutalize and even
kill your black brothers and sisters
with impunity when you see the vast
majority of your twenty million Negro
brothers smothering in an airtight cage
of poverty in the midst of an affluent
society when you suddenly find your
tongue twisted in your speech stammering
as you seek to explain to your
six-year-old daughter why she cannot go
to the public amusement park that has
just been advertised on television when
you take a cross-country drive and find
it necessary to sleep night after night
in the uncomfortable corners of your
automobile because no motel will accept
you when you are humiliated day in and
day out by nagging signs reading white
and colored then you will understand why
we find it difficult to wait I've read
this many times but every time I read it
and this is just an excerpt it as you
can tell it's incredibly powerful and
encourage you to read it in its entirety
and think about why this was such a
powerful document especially for
catalyzing things like the Civil Rights
Act of 1964